[Music]
we're going to start with george
galloway
on my left hand side is professor
stephen pinker peter hitchens as you see
is very much present professor noam
chomsky who one almost says needs no
introduction but of course immensely
distinguished public intellectual
being a labour mp an mp for respect
columnist for the mail on sunday of
harvard university one of the
best known public intellectuals in the
world
could we invite you to lay out the moral
position of the right since we've had
the left
i don't speak for them no but you you're
right
my moral position is that morality is is
for individuals but i do think that
it's getting very hard uh in a society
with an increasingly strong
interfering state a state which uh in my
view intervenes very much on behalf
of uh of commerce and business
to make people's lives more and more
subject to the needs of business
and whose cynical alliance with what i
think is now fourth stage feminism
is really all about getting as many
women into the workplace as
cheap uh compliant wage slaves as it
could possibly manage
i think this particular cynical alliance
has done enormous damage to personal and
private life
in our country i think that the basis of
freedom in any country is private life
and i think the basis of private life is
strong families
and i think that both commerce and the
state dislike strong families intensely
and want to get rid of them and so we
see this desert
uh of uh of zero hours contracts and
and low-wage jobs in which nobody can
afford
uh what would it what a normal british
working class family of the 1950s 60s
and 70s would have seen as
normal a one income being enough to live
on so we all have to go out and slave
for next to nothing
uh for for global corporations and this
somehow
uh has come into alliance with uh with
the cause which considers itself to be
feminist
i i do not disagree with anything in
anything at all in virginia woolf's a
room of one's own i think it's an
absolutely perfect statement of the
feminist case
i don't think that feminism was ever
about the destruction of family life
or the regimenting of women into wage
slavery uh as it has become and i think
feminism actually interested in in the
in the
in the welfare of women it wouldn't go
down this thread but then you've just
made the case surely you have just made
the case
against the politics of interest rather
than a politics morality
i'm sorry so can you put it so say it
again haven't you just made the case
against the politics which is defined by
interest rather than with the moral
say i'm saying that that a policy which
which presents itself as moral is in
fact
is in fact a policy of of commercial
interest and the pursuit of power
uh which is so very often the case and
this is this this is what idealist
politics is about it presents
uh hard uh commercial and political
interests as a moral case and people are
fooled by it and then they
find afterwards that they were fooled
well i think it's too late
and i i'm afraid that for about 20 years
now
from my own position originally
believing that i could do
some good i put deliberately in front
of people on the left such as chris and
many others
a series of objections to the the
policies they were pursuing
whether they were policies on education
whether they were policies
on crime and punishment whether they
were policies on immigration i said
these policies are ignore so completely
the real position and the plight
particularly of the poor in our country
that you are storing up for yourselves a
great rebellion against you
uh which will be much less nice than i
am and you don't think i
you don't think i'm nice so you wait and
see and i said this and i said this and
i said i got nothing
but scorn and rejection and i can live
with that personally you know i
my own life is is blessed uh it doesn't
make any real difference to me and i
should be dead soon so the consequences
of it don't matter very much but
the truth was that i was genuinely
trying to argue with the left who had it
seemed to me
taken control of politics the academy
the civil service and the law
they had a responsibility to listen
otherwise they were risking something
this was
weimar and they were risking something
horrible afterwards and now they have
donald trump
and they don't realize it was their
fault and now they have the referendum
result and they don't realize it was
their fault to this day they have not
understood
that it was their own behavior which led
to these consequences and the
i hate the division of this country at
the moment over the european issue on
which i am
not what most people expect i i very
much favor the norway option i refused
to take any part in the referendum
campaign i didn't vote in it
and people automatically assume because
i'm right wing that i'm
jacob rees-mogg it's not so there are
other there are other positions which
one can take
and i regret enormously and i look
looking back at the history of my own
country
i can think only of the periods of
munich and sewage as comparable times
when people genuinely stopped speaking
to each other which is a disaster
for civil society but it's not my fault
it's your fault for paying
no attention whatever right to the
incessant attempts by by
by people such as me to say to you
you've got this wrong you're
ignoring really important people you're
ignoring the poor in this country and
the
the lives that they're living and and
you will eventually pay the price and
now you're paying it well
we've got that okay it's my only
pleasure in life my only pleasure
in public life say i told you it is to
say i told you something
i am the the chief of the i told you so
industry and all my books on the site
which say i told you sir are in the
tent out there well no no now we're
clear on that donald trump
is an unpredictable unstable person
he's not a strong and stable genius
he's a bull in a china shop and to mix
the metaphor even a stop clock is right
twice a day and he was right
to meet with the north korean
leadership and he was right to encourage
a rapprochement between north and south
korea and it's going swimmingly
in fact it's practically a loving the
koreans
are embracing each other with a warmth
and vigor that no one could possibly
have imagined
and donald trump's predecessors would
never have permitted
this is important barack obama would
never have met kim jong-un
and therefore the permafrost of
north-south korea relations
would have continued so and
not only would barack obama not have
done it hillary clinton would not have
done it
and so if we are looking objectively
at this thing you have to say
that trump was right
about korea and the others were wrong
because korea has been four decades
a clear and present danger to
world peace and uh and stability
it's not that i'm passionately
denouncing the rules-based international
order
i'm passionately denouncing the fact
that there is no
rules-based international order you just
call lawlessness a rules-based
international order
with some mistakes some breaches
but how many breaches does it take
to invalidate your thesis in the first
place
if you have what you call an
international rules-based
system in the world which is not just
breached
not just mistakes but which
kills millions of people and renders the
whole world
completely unstable how many times does
that need to
happen before your thesis is invalidated
now for most people
it long ago ceased to be credible
to call it a rules-based international
order
and i refuse to accept your thesis
that's all
i haven't got a thesis i'm just asking
you two what you think well your thesis
is that there is an international rules
based
oh i see and and and my case is that
it's abundantly clear that there has not
been
and that therefore attempts to
exceptionalize trump
which is the liberal mantra
are nonsense he's only been in 23 months
so if we have the world was in total
chaos before he came
so so if we hadn't had the united
nations and nato
set up after the second world war do you
think the world would have been a better
place no
because i believe in a united nations
with real authority but as long as
you have veto powers it cannot possibly
guarantee international order i support
the united nations
it's it's tony blair and george w bush
that walked out of the united nations
and caused the cataclysm which is being
i think under appreciated here of the
iraq war
not since the first world war did we
take a decision
that would so change the world as the
decision to invade
iraq now
the united nations dick the late
kofi annan described that at the time
as an illegal act and yet it was carried
out by people who pretend that they are
presiding over
a rules-based international order
certainly the the rise of
authoritarian nationalist populism
paradoxically
depends on a dystopian uh
vision of contemporary society most
notoriously in uh the american president
donald trump whose uh
inauguration speech whose campaign uh
advertisements painted a picture of the
country as
consumed by war and terrorism and
unemployment and
failing schools and uh paradoxically
that narrative was um abetted or at
least it certainly
excuse me wasn't countered by large
segments of the left that
kind of agreed that society is is uh
circling the drain
so not only was the populist message of
decline
not countered but it also left large
numbers of people
disengaged from politics altogether a
lot of people who detested donald trump
stayed home on election day figuring
well uh hillary clinton part of the same
corrupt establishment what difference
does it make
and to some extent brexit uh passed by
some of the same dynamic
the especially younger people who
uh were opposed to brexit uh
stayed home on election day and uh and
so the
the uh the plebiscite went the way it
did
so um you describe you know voices on
the alt-right you described it on the
old left are you then
the old center i never uh
thought of myself that way but in in the
chapter on reason i point out that one
of the
uh one of the biggest sources of
unreason of irrationality
is uh political tribalism that people
simply assume
that uh all these solutions proposed by
the left or the right
as the case may be are known to be
correct
as a result become impervious to
counter-arguments
to data to evidence i suggest that
since none of us is omniscient or
infallible enough to know what will
solve society's problems we have to take
an open mind
look at uh be informed by history by
data
by uh but by evidence keep an open mind
and uh try to converge on the
mix of policies that have proven
themselves to result the the
in the greatest benefits to human
well-being my favorite comment on the
trump uh carnage inauguration speech
came from
former president george w bush a man
with whom i tend not to agree to put it
mildly
and he said that was some weird [ __ ]
but uh speaking to your point though
your your observation about human
psychology is correct there is a
well-documented phenomenon known as the
negativity bias
one version of it is the uh phenomenon
of loss aversion that daniel kahneman
and amos turski documented
that people dread losses more than they
savor or anticipate gains
criticism stings more than praise uh
elevates we have a better memory for
uh things that go wrong than things the
things that can go right
however it is not true that that uh
political rhetoric
therefore must appeal to the negative
because there have been fantastically
successful politicians
who have had a note of optimism even in
dark times
perhaps most famous well franklin
roosevelt we have nothing to fear but
fear itself yeah
um on the on the right ronald reagan
during a period of double-digit
inflation
and unemployment had an optimistic
message barack obama
not so long ago was elected twice with a
message of hope and change
so it can be done by a skillful
politician pops things aren't miserable
enough for donald trump's message to be
overturned
so so here's my my question you know you
make a very coherent argument for
looking on the bright side you know
you're a husk you know glass half full
guy how come there is really no
politician
of prominence in america that is able
to come up with that message or indeed
in this country
but where the kind of where the lovers
of the other thing no i think that
that's a it's a good question by the way
it's
the the message of the book is not let's
look at the let's see the glass as half
full
it's uh let's let's see how full the
glass is again the problem is
this is not a book about optimism this
is a book about accuracy
uh the the fact that global property has
declined by
uh 50 in 30 years is not looking at the
bright side it's a fact that people
don't know
so if we look at the europeans
who makes the basic decision yeah okay
it's not the national state the basic
decisions are made by
uh troika the imf unelected
commission and the central bank in
upward and brussels
and the reason one of the reasons why
you're seeing in europe the spread of
populism being opposition to the
establishment established institutions
to the centrist center left parties that
have
governed the country plenty of
opposition uh
rage anger fear part of the reason is
that the decision-making has in fact
been further removed it was always quite
remote
further removed from people themselves
and the decisions that are being made at
the
high level beyond popular control or
basically respond to the northern banks
that are not to the population
the level of austerity the
version of neoliberalism has had dire
economic effects on
large parts of the population than it is
anger from
when we turn here is trump listening to
his constituencies yeah
now he has one major legislative
achievement so far
what thomas joseph stiglitz probably
calls
the uh the donor
tax bill of 1917
bill which harms the general population
harms trump's constituency benefit
is actual constituency which is
concentrated wealth and corporate power
what we've been observing in the united
states for the last
year
it's a sensible system in which
the figure in the white house uh
focuses attention on himself her total
media attention on trump
and his antics
showing up the false of yesterday
which has now been forgotten and while
he's doing that
the more savage wing of the republican
party
ryan mcconnell and the rest were ramming
through
legislation which is extremely harmful
to their
pretended constituency their voters and
everyone else
and in fact to the world in general
though we cannot forget
why the doomsday block has moved for two
minutes to midnight
that's an overwhelming fact surpassing
everything else we're discussing and
it's largely because of these
uh actions that are being taken under
the cover of trump's attitudes
it's a good game it plays very well but
it's extremely dangerous
yeah and it's eating rage anger
irrationality and sometimes support for
charismatic figures and claim to
represent it
in fact they're working for other
interests
to watch all the full talks and debates
from these highlights
find the links below in the description
and subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas
you